qui était un temps j il ya deux ans
désormais et remis sur le tapis dire que
entendre pour cela von der laan qui est
la présidente allemande de la cd ou
président de la commission européenne
qui vous explique qu'il ne faut surtout
pas à renouer avec les règles de
stabilité budgétaire c'est-à-dire avec
le pacte de stabilité trop vie parce
c'est ce qui a entraîné justement la
longue des primes de la croissance post
crise de la zone euro parce que non mais
trop c'est trop la cellule en trop
rapidement et donc il faut revoir les
règles du pacte de stabilité budgétaire
que leur matière d'aidés d'état il faut
se laisser suspendu l'ensemble des reds
européenne s'est complètement facilement
il ya deux ans elle n'est juste pas
possible ici véritablement je crois que
le les vieux logiciels ont explosé en
plein vol
je veux bien c'est clair parce que je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça fonctionne
franchement je m'attendais pas à ce que
l'aîné massive
des budgets étatiques permet de
maintenir l'économie à flot et mieux la
relancer de façon pressel et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il ya deux ans donc je reconnais même
pas les maxima coupable ce qui paie mais
parce que depuis trente ans on vivait
effectivement dans des croyances
injustifiée et ça ça peut aussi
atteindre les allemands vous jamais
désespérer de l'allemagne et de sa
capacité à s'adapter
[Musique]